the reason why you are not getting
approached is because these men see you
as a woman with high value oh no no no
this is the truth like I'm trying to be
kind I they'd probably approach women
that look friendlier I would say you
probably look like that's probably why
you are better than them men can sense
if a woman is better than them and that
intimidates them that
just oh no the I'm intimidating woman
I'm literally
so this guy I am a alone with my son by
myself a woman and a male approached me
in a parking lot he's Excuse Me Miss and
I don't know why in the hell he was
approaching me and I turned around and I
literally yelled at him and I said do
not approach
me what if he's like excuse me ma'am you
dropped
this what up guys welcome to the just
pearly things YouTube channel and
welcome welcome to my reaction series
before I start don't forget to like the
video on your way in and subscribe to
the channel and bring that notification
Bell also get yourself a women shouldn't
vote t-shirt as you guys know none of
this craziness would be going on if
women didn't get the right to vote let's
take it back let's move this Overton
window okay so today I'm reacting to the
video modern women are frustrated about
men's refusing to approach them when
they hit the wall let's go it's like
this huge problem that I've been
noticing in the dating world the oh and
for the people that don't know what the
wall is um the age is disputed when
exactly women hit it but it's
essentially when women realize that they
can't compete the way they did when they
were 18 now some women get fat and they
hit this at 25 some women stay in great
shape and it's 35 but let's just say
it's somewhere between the ages of 25
and 35 good good respectful men the men
with
boundaries will not approach roach women
because they're trying to respect their
boundaries and it is true that
biologically speaking women are far more
attuned to subtleties like body language
subtleties than men so a lot of times
women will actually be giving off Clues
and cues that they want to be approached
but it's more of like they're trying to
give off yeah chivalry is dead and women
killed it and basically because of these
like toxic feminist women that you know
have given guys all these [__] just been
terrible when they approach them now men
don't want to approach it's too much
trouble VI or something and the man has
no idea what ends up happening is that
it's the men with No Boundaries or that
don't respect boundaries or the
narcissists or the creeps that end well
it's more like the men that practiced
approaching that have approached
thousands of women so you're just kind
of an option to him that appro yeah
that's I would agreeing the woman and
then there's whole camps in like classes
where men learn to do this stuff women
in my life complain that it's only the
creeps that approach them when it's
really we women need to be giving off
way more okay this serious question for
the guys I have this conversation with
my female friends I think like I'm not
even kidding once a week so I'm just
curious what the real reasoning is
behind it but most of my girlfriends say
that whenever they're out they never get
approached by guys ever and maybe like
one girl in the friend group who does
get approached it's not like she's a
total standout out from the group but
for some reason like a specific girl
might just like get hit on a lot I don't
know but not even in a bias way I I
think that some of my friends are very
very beautiful like actually I'm not
just saying that to be nice so it makes
me really curious as to why guys don't
go up to them is it like one even if you
see an attractive girl like you're just
hanging out with your friends you don't
really care two you're just simply not
attracted to her three maybe you like
think she's just like in a relationship
or like she's she just super standoffish
and like [__] looking or like in
general you just like don't want to deal
with any type of rejection like is it is
it the guys point of view or is it just
like the girls are putting out this
weird vibe or like just guys don't find
them mat I I don't know and it's
unfortunate because it's like the women
of today suffer for the sins of women's
past where a lot of evil is really
coming from these women that have like
LED women astray this has been going on
for 50 years guys there's nothing new on
Under The Sun It's actually older than
that but I would say like the' 7s 60s
was sort of like the cultural shift
where the feminist became the norm
rather than the exception most of my
friends like want to meet guys in person
but then they go out and just like
nothing really happens so what is it so
it's been brought to my attention that
men no longer want to come up to women
anymore due to sex allegations women
being just so rude and disrespectful and
and rejection I didn't know that was a
thing I didn't know men didn't want to
come up to women anymore I'm barely
finding this out why do women choose to
cuss guys out when they come up to them
and approach them I have no idea I
apologize it's basically dependent on
how attractive the guy is is how the
women treat them for that but there's
just too many fine men and if it takes
me the women being having to come up to
you guys and shooting my shot saying
what's up being the big stepper then
I'll just have to do that and I'm going
just start coming up to you guys and
shooting out compliments and see where
it takes me so if I start coming up to
y'all in the grocery store and I say
Excuse me sir you are just so sexy I
want a response okay I don't want n of
that shy stuff how I feel after going
out in public and getting zero
compliments zero people approaching me
zero people asking me for my number when
this is a known thing for girls to
experience y'all I could not relate more
like I swear not even the construction
workers want me like I could walk in New
York by a construction site nobody would
say anything I know this isn't something
that you should want but after a while
it's like Dam yeah yeah that's what I
said women will never appreciate what we
have until it's gone and we're getting
more antisocial and the men are just
thinking this is too much work I I don't
I don't want these chicks to start
crying about it later I heard about a
guy who was in London he was doing
interviews and he got kicked off of the
campus for harassment and he wasn't even
hitting on chicks imagine if he was
hitting on chicks I know it and I've
heard it from men saying why they don't
approach me the reason why you are not
getting approached is because these men
see you as a woman with high value a lot
of men oh no oh no want to have fun so
they go and push themselves on women
that they think don't have high value
this is the truth like I'm trying to be
kind I I they'd probably approach women
that look friendlier I would say you
probably look like a [__] that's
probably why but that is the truth if
you are not getting approach in a place
where everyone's breaking their necks to
stare at you only women could find a way
to rationalize that if there's no buyers
somehow your price is higher than you
originally thought they know that if
they approach you you will hurt their
ego and they know that you are better
than them men can sense if a woman is
better than them and that intimidates
them that just oh no the I'm
intimidating woman I'm scared like oh
[__] like no no woman can be better than
me personally I take this as a
compliment if I'm out in public getting
a lot of stairs all right y here's the
question why men don't approach women
anymore H glad you asked let's get into
it family happy Saturday everybody
number one the fear of rejection women
today as we know have some unrealistic
standards some women unless he has a six
six figure and his six feet you can't
talk to him number two it's not just
about the fear of rejection for some men
it's the fear of being labeled a creep
or Predator because the man that's
approaching you isn't your
type so because he's interested in you
he a creep come on now number three
online dating which has made it so men
don't have to get rejected in person
number four I can't say a lot of men are
excited about online dating if you look
at the numbers guys Mo most men I
wouldn't say that's a factor I would say
it's more it just I just think it's a
juice isn't worth the squeeze you know I
think they just like you know what this
just too much work media now you can
just run up in somebody DM you don't
have to have communication skills I
think all this technology and everything
has made our communication skill
terrible y'all terrible and last we've
seen how women will reject men in
unnecessarily rude ways it's okay to not
be in to try to embarrass the y' we
taking right now cuz I just had a man
approached me in a parking lot and it
went fine and I'm going to tell you why
it went fine and how to address it
because it was in a book I read and and
this is how you're supposed to address
it but it scared me oh no oh no lit I'm
literally shaking so this guy I am a
alone with my son by myself a woman and
a male approached me in a parking lot
he's Excuse Me Miss and I don't know why
in the hell he was approaching me or
what he was trying to do and before he I
mean he was probably 30 ft from me when
he said excuse me ma'am and I turned
around and I literally yelled at him and
I said do not approach me and he like
what if he's like excuse me ma'am you
dropped this it's always the single
mothers like come on immediately started
going in the other direction and I just
kept saying it over and over and over I
said do not approach me how [__]
crazy are you that that is your reaction
when someone's coming up to you do not
approach me and he of course like got
like what the f did like he started
cussing and yelling like what what's
your problem and I said yeah cuz that's
crazy I looked at him and he started he
she's watched one too many crime
documentaries actually then crossed a
couple cars down from my car he didn't
come anywhere near me he crossed a
couple cars down from my car and was
like what's continuing to cuss and say
what's your problem and I say you do not
approach women in a parking lot I just
kept saying do not approach me you do
not approach women in a parking lot like
yeah she seems like a lot of she seems
like a lot of fun no male should ever
approach a woman in a parking lot all
right guys thank you so much for coming
back to my channel so you have heard
everything for yourself I mean the more
active yeah so this this is what's
happening guys this is the reality of
the situation men don't approach because
they're sick and tired of this [__]
they'll hear about one girl giving a
friend a guy a super negative reaction
and getting recorded it just shows men
everywhere that the juice isn't worth
the squeeze and this will never change
until women you know I really think we
we're going to be in a place where women
approach men in 10 like 10 15 years I
bet you the norm is going to be that
women approach men cuz they're just
going to get so sick of this [__] well
let me know what you guys think in the
comments guys make sure you subscribe to
the channel ring that notification Bell
and get yourself a women CH of vote
t-shirt I'll talk to you next time